sometimes unscripted moments breathe
more life into a scene
the adults are talking and other times
they i'm so sorry
fall short luckily in the mcu the
improvisation gene is impeccably strong
amongst its actors
so in this video we're taking you
through all of spider-man's unscripted
moments that completely took the films
to another level
action we all know tony stark isn't one
to get himself caught up in emotional
moments and in spider-man homecoming
peter parker
learned that in a pretty awkward way
after tony stark has a talk with peter
in his car
he reaches over to open the car door but
peter thinks he's actually leaning in
for a hug
remember that's not a hug i'm just
grabbing the door for you
well check out what tom holland had to
say about the scene well that was
actually an improvised
moment i think i just tried to hug him i
just thought it would be funny if i
hugged him
the hilarious moment was completely
improvised for laughs but robert downey
jr went along with it
speaking about tony stark and his
emotions during the final moments of
avengers
infinity war he was nothing but
emotional same mr stark
as spider-man turned into nothingness in
his arms we were all a puddle of tears
when he desperately chants
i don't want to go i don't want to go
start please oh you didn't want to go
that was all tom holland again the
director gave him free reign on the
death scene
and tom delivered even if he doesn't
think it was that spectacular himself
i don't want to go three times in a row
so it's not that
amazing of an ad-lib it's hard to
believe spider-man is one of tom's first
big roles
tom holland and zendaya's chemistry is
off the charts
peter parker and mj are like magic on
screen together
and a lot of that is thanks to the
actor's off-screen friendship
according to zendaya tom has a habit of
deviating from the script
but thankfully they're so in tune with
one another that she was able to respond
right back
no matter how annoyed she was it just
kept improving he just did not stick to
the script he was trying to throw me off
what's your favorite peter in mj scene
she knows i told her
he didn't tell me i figured it out if
there's one thing better than watching
peter and mj on screen
it's watching peter mj and ned interact
with one another
but the truth is a lot of the time we're
watching their off-screen relationships
shine through the camera
remember in spider-man far from home ned
walks in on mj and peter while he's
changing into his spider-man suit
the costume looks great for the costume
party
well ned wasn't in on the fact that mj
had found out their secret and tried to
play it off
ned's actor jacob batalon actually said
that was one of his favorite scenes to
shoot
because he got to improv all his
comments there was a lot of laughter on
set that day
we have to give jake gyllenhaal credit
for playing such a convincing role as
mysterio
who knew that he would actually turn out
as a villain in the end but it looks
like we should be praising jake for more
than just his impeccable acting skills
according to the actor he and director
john watts came up with a lot of
unscripted moments for his character
that ended up in the film
we don't know what specific scenes these
moments are in but let's just appreciate
mysterio for a sec
somebody get this stupid costume off me
having at may be played by a younger
actress in the marvel universe gave us a
whole other perspective on her
relationship with peter
it's so comforting to see the two of
them interact on screen
but you'll be shocked to find out that a
lot of their scenes were unscripted as
well
one specific improvised moment in
spider-man homecoming happened while
they're eating in the thai restaurant
how many times you have to say larb
before you talk to me
you know i larp you their conversation
was just something the actor made up on
the fly with some guidance from the
director
yet again we have another improvised
moment between peter parker and tony
stark
this time it's in captain america civil
war check it out
i'm gonna sit here so you move the leg
tony stark telling peter to move over
might seem like it was in character
and it is but it was also robert downey
jr's way of telling tom holland to scoot
over onto his set marker without ruining
the entire take
funnily enough it ended up in the final
cut can you even
see in these yes yes i can't look i
can't
samuel l jackson got his moment to shine
in spider-man as his character nick fury
he even got sassy with spider-man
although the line wasn't even scripted
when peter admits he's a little hesitant
to join their newest plan
fury says [ __ ] please you've been to
space samuel l jackson may not have
recalled whether the line was improvised
but jake gyllenhaal
jumped in to confirm it was 100
unscripted
i'm here to attest that was improvised
despite his hesitancy with nick fury
peter was all in for helping out iron
man on his avengers infinity war mission
but tony stark wasn't having it or
should we say robert downey jr wasn't
having it
while iron man is having a discussion
with dr strange peter chimes in that
he's back up i'm back up no
you're still away the adults are talking
but that was yet again another
improvised line between the unscripted
heroes tom holland and robert downey jr
spider-man far from home
is full of european landmarks that make
the entire movie stunning
even if a lot of them do get destroyed
according to a screen rant interviewer
a lot of improvising happened in a
specific landmark the london tower
the film's final battle takes place in
london and supposedly during this scene
the cast shot so many versions because
of their ability to improvise
you'd never be able to tell in the final
cut they joined forces like the power
rangers
you think you get voltron voltron you
think you're full try
drax's line i'll do you one better why
is gamora is one of the funniest
highlights that came out of avengers
infinity war
even if spider-man's life was literally
being threatened in the scene
the line however was actually ad-libbed
by drax's actor
dave bautista the rest of the actors
including tom holland are just so
professional that they rolled with it
the camera operator even seemed to be
quick to react
michael keaton got some time to shine in
spider-man homecoming but one of his
best
lines didn't make the final cut
according to tom holland
keaton actually made a direct reference
to his role as batman
in the 80s his character vulture is a
little confused as to why spider-man
would save him
and after tom holland delivers his
because i'm spider-man
keaton supposedly responded but i'm
batman
we don't know if the line was part of
the script but tom holland seemed to be
hinting
it was ad-libbed like we mentioned
before jake gyllenhaal played the
perfect mysterio
and a lot of why his character is so
epic may be because of how well he got
along with tom holland
according to tom mysterio and spider-man
were actually meant to bump heads a lot
however while filming their interactions
turned out to be more friendly
the directors decided to let them head
off the script and build their own
relationship between the characters
they basically became bffs good luck kid
i'll give you about a 50 50 chance
you're pretty awkward so
we also see spidey's actual bff ned get
his own romantic interest
but according to ned's actor jacob
batalon ned's relationship with betty
was basically developed by him and
actress and gory rice
he says they were given a lot of space
for improv they may not have lasted
super long as a couple but there's no
doubt they were adorable
i would totally kiss you but i think i
just threw up in my mouth a little
i i might have a mint it seems like
jacob batalon had a lot to do with all
his characters relationships with the
chemistry between peter and ned
we've never doubted the way they were
childhood best friends and the chemistry
between the actors off screen
is why it's so authentic apparently
because tom and jacob weren't given the
script days in advance
they never knew their lines which means
their interactions are purely the two
actors playing off one another
do you know him too yeah
if we needed any more proof that tom
holland is holding his own when it comes
to the rest of the marvel cast
this video is it watching these actors
not only play superheroes but
be superheroes when it comes to bringing
to life a character
is nothing short of impressive let us
know if you have any other unscripted
spider-man moments we should discuss
thanks for watching the things fans
[Music]
you